I want to introduce
[Music]
who I will speak today about building a
search engine and as I understand it's
beginner friendly
and
um at the end of this Workshop you
should be empowered to also build a type
of search engine so the speaker today is
a machine learning engineer at Walmart
search and came to us from New York
thank you thanks everyone for joining um
apologies I'm a little bit under the
weather so sorry if my voice is a bit of
course
um yeah so since this is a workshop if
you would like to follow along I haven't
Jupiter out instance where you know all
the code all the
data models already pre-downloaded so we
won't necessarily waste any time with
all the setups so if you would like to
follow along you know please access that
link
um you may be asked to indicate with
your GitHub
and just create an account there
um you could also just you know watch
while we work to the notebooks and the
slides and the code are available at the
GitHub repo
this link is also available in the
speaker
in the property at Pi data
yeah as was mentioned I'm currently a
machine learning engineer at the moment
search team you can find my LinkedIn and
my email here but the information that
I'm going to be presenting is not
necessarily you know endorsement for my
employer or anything it's more like what
I see from like the general search base
in general
so there are about four topics I would
like to cover today and the way I
structured this is it's going to be like
a mixture of maybe like four or five
slides kind of introducing the topic to
make sure we're all kind of in the same
page
and then kind of a notebook that kind of
explore the idea a little bit further
so we'll start first with token based
retrieval which is a classical way to
build a search engine
then we'll cover embedding base
retrieval which is the newer you know
fancier way to kind of solve this
problem
then given there's time we'll look at
how we can scale embedding base
retrievals the vector databases and a m
and then we'll apply the things that we
learned together by looking at an
example of uh how one company kind of
incorporates all these ideas as their
stack
so
I kind of was hoping this material would
be kind of beginner friendly so you know
if you are new to the field of search or
you have never worked on it you know I
think
hopefully you know maybe empowered and
it's accessible if you are new or a
beginner in the in the field of NLP I
think this material is still will be
useful but you know if you're already
familiar with embeddings if you're
already using them in production
um the material may not be as new but
hopefully there's still some value
so what I hope by the end of the session
um that you can take away is you know on
top of understanding things like
token-based retrieval and embedding
based retrieval you're able to leave it
you know like if you have a given the
opportunity to work on a data set you're
able to use like elasticsearch to build
a token based cable system uh use like
open source uh models from the hugging
phase Hub to generate embeddings and
building embedding based ritual system
and then kind of understand how you
might be able to scale this with a
vector database or with internet
so
um
so if you want to follow along again
the link is you know
training so I'm just going to go over
like one first notebook which
um
you don't need to necessarily run it
it's just to kind of get familiar with
what the data set that will be working
with today looks like
so after you log in it may take like two
or three minutes for like the node to
scale up
um maybe this is a bit small let me just
zoom in a little bit
so once the instance gets provisioned
you should see that get repo search
engine Workshop
just basically the sweep upload
and let's look at notebooks
and let's look at this notebook setup
stacks
so I'm just going to uh in interest of
time I'm just going to look at the cells
up output
so the data set that we are working with
is from this website unsplashed which is
basically a photography yes
oh sure
um
is this better yeah
thanks
yes so the data set that we'll be
looking at is from this website
on splash.com which is basically like a
photography website
so one of the files that they provide us
is their kind of search logs so let's
use this to kind of understand what type
of queries their users are coming to
this platform to search for
so the raw data that they provide us is
like this user ID came at this time the
search for this word clouds and then
they downloaded this image so this is
the raw session data that you get from
this
I'm just going to aggregate this and
just we're just going to look at it in
general what type of queries uh this
platform is getting
so if we look at the top ways we see
things like nature Sky flowers
receive flowers and flower we see a
mountain
and we see like mountains so in general
it seems like most of the queries that
are coming to this platform are just one
word and they're about nature and like
there's no normalization that's
happening for the query that's why you
see things like flower flowers mountain
mountains
um I think these these terms that are a
bit broad like it's not necessarily
clear what the intent or what an ideal
result might be for this results so
let's look at maybe queries that have
more than one term
so if you look at ways that have at
least four terms you know we think we
start getting things like
um Mountain star live landscape night
sky things like light at the end of the
tunnel you get a slogan like there's no
Planet B
like things like image of a man in the
password so we can get some good players
that we can kind of test what our system
might look like
so the queries in general that kind of
caught my eye
are
go back to the slides
um
this place so these are some ways that
we'll kind of look at how our retrieval
system looks at
so now we understand what is the search
traffic that comes to this platform
let's look at actually what is the data
that we actually have for the images
so
again in the interest of time I'm just
going to
um this might be a large notebook so
it may not render at least
it looks like it is fine
images are too big let me just go to the
slides
so the
um again since this is a photography
website we basically have an image and
an option so there are things like
um for the image on the left you have
wooden ball on Sand Beach so the images
are of very high quality but the
captions are maybe
not descriptive enough
um on the other hand on the right hand I
have right hand side you see an image
where it's maybe kind of like a
Instagram kind of caption where
it doesn't really tell enough about the
picture itself
so we we have a different we have like
kind of descriptions
two ends of technical
so we looked at sample queries that are
coming in the platform we looked at what
the sample data set looks like so now
let's look at building the first
um search engine approach for solving
this problem
so the first possible way to solve this
is token based retrieval
so the first open-based retrieval is
something called Boolean retrieval
so let's say you have this query like
pictures of Kit and plane a user entered
this on your platform
so it comes to your back end as the
string
so you need to process it so normally
like how in my processes is maybe a
sequence of tree operations the first
thing is you break that string into
tokens or words
since this is the English language it
might be fine to just ask split or Break
It by white space to prevent some
pictures is keep in plain and we have
now an array of four tokens
The Next Step you might do is to remove
stockwards so
in English you know there are some words
that appear common in many sentences
things like the ER and of which maybe it
might not add much value so we just
remove them from consideration so in our
case we remove the word off
the other thing is stemming so stemming
is basically you kind of um if you look
at the word playing and playing it
basically means I'm the same thing so
you basically map a verb sorry a word to
its root phone so pictures become
pictures you know playing becomes plain
so now you have your three tokens
so
um
you can either like look for documents
that contain all three terms or
documents that contain at least one of
these terms or the maximum of these
terms so let's look at three documents
so the first document is images of Jack
plane
um one thing to note is the processing
that you do for a query you also need to
do it
for a document
so the word plain plane
um
the document one it gets a score of one
because one of the tokens match
uh one thing to note is in document one
we see there's the word images
pictures and images semantically mean
the same thing but if we just look at
pure tokens
um
it doesn't it's not a smart enough to
understand that pictures and images are
synonyms
uh likewise kitten and cat
meme can mean the same thing
but again because we don't consider them
semantically similar this this approach
doesn't
account for that
the second document videos having fun
having fun and playing basically means
the same thing but again because of this
vocabulary mismatch
the only score that the second document
gets is Forgiven
now let's look at document three
document 3 looks like it's a mystical
basically it has an N number of
sentences
and technically this document has all
the terms
but is this document more relevant
we see the terms appear
the chicken is not playing the kitten is
sleeping
it's a dog who's playing but technically
this document contains all the terms
so is this document more relevant
um I would argue that maybe it is not
relevant but based on this approach
um this document gets the highest score
so how can we improve this approach
um like maybe before that I'm just kind
of summarizing uh what we did with
Boolean retrieval so basically a great
mistaken and it was converted to a bag
of words or a list
and you can when you're selecting your
Corpus you can use a Boolean operator
like or and to see to get the relevant
documents
and some of the disadvantages that we
saw
you know it considers tokens and
considers the exact match doesn't have
an idea of like synonyms or semantics
semantic Concepts
it doesn't consider it like
um it keeps all tokens with the same
words and same thing so like
for the face pictures of kitten playing
like the word picture doesn't really
mean
much right it could be pictures GIF
videos they all could probably mean the
same thing the
concept that is more important in that
sentence is the word kitten or maybe
playing
but this approach doesn't really capture
that idea and the last thing is it
doesn't consider a document type
documentary is the largest document but
it gets a high score
so how can we build a better
algorithm
so let's see if we can answer a few
things
so
we want to balance two things you want
to balance
um
the first idea is if a token appears
often in a document
then that document is probably about
that idea
but the other thing is if a dog if I
don't that's right
if a token appears in a lot of documents
then maybe that token is not really
important
if we have 50 documents all talking
about one idea and then that idea or a
word it's not really unique
I'm sorry
so the two ideas that we talked about
are
token frequency and inverse document
frequency
not just the scientific way of basically
capturing that idea
so let's add one more addition
to this
so if you have a document that has the
term
if you have two documents one document
Has September five times and added a
document as the term appear 50 times is
document 2 10 times more important
because it has the term appearing 10
times more
probably not right just because the term
appears in a document
that many times it doesn't mean it's 10
times important it could be maybe two
times more important
so you want to kind of limit
how much contribution this token
frequency is given
so there are two ways that that does it
so one you want to kind of limit on the
maximum contribution of this token
frequency
and the other thing is you want to
consider a document like
um longer documents have more
probability
so
this is conceptually the idea now I'm
going to this for one I'm going to show
this in the mathematical manner
so this is that idea
automatically expressed
I kind of color coordinated for these
ideas
the exact formula is not really
important
but just kind of showing that this idea
can be expressed
that and this idea of this formula is
being 25 the classic information
material outline there's a simpler
version of this of KF IDF but efidf M25
this is basically the idea
it's trying to match token sequencing
and inverse document frequency
um so this is Matt I'm not going to
implement this from scratch I hope this
open source solutions that add this
algorithm
search is
um in open source search engine
um yeah other Solutions like solar that
are basically built on top of the same
Library
uh luckily it implements bm-25 and other
algorithms so you don't have to
implement this from scratch
and on top of that when you do token
match you know you can do things like
whether you want to
when you search whether you want all the
terms to appear whether you want some of
the terms to appear you can do things
like if a term appears in a DOT like in
title of a paper then it's more
important than it if it appears in the
abstract of the paper so you can kind of
create very powerful search periods with
this approach
and it is production writing so you know
it can scale for a large number of
documents
so that's all I wanted to cover for
token based retrieval
so let's actually go and kind of see how
we can do this in the lab
so again if you want to follow along
here is the link
um I'm just going to duplicate this
notebook in case the
presentation guards are not kind to me
so let me just clear this
so
the goal for this notebook is to
basically understand the built-in
uh tokenizers or analyzers that are
available in elasticsearch
and to see how we can use elastic
searches API to basically index
documents and to retrieve documents
using this
so
so I'm just going to run a voice cell
the cell is just Imports nothing too
interesting
one thing to note has been importing two
two packages from elasticsearch
so let's look at the raw data set
so the data set has about 25 000 images
it has all these metadata
but for today the only thing that we
really care about
is really the description
so I have an elasticsearch cluster
running locally inside this notebook
so you don't need to install the last
six inch it's already available locally
elasticsearch has a concept called index
you can think of it as like a table or a
database
so now let's look at elastic searches
built in analyzer so analyzer is
basically given a query what are the
steps it does the processes they're
putting
so there is a helpful method in your
elasticsearch cluster like slash
underscore analyze right given a word or
given a query you can tell it how would
you actually process this token
so I have this synthetic sentence here
two dogs walking in the snow a snow
emoji and some Chinese capture
so the first analyzer that we look at is
this white space analyzer
so as you can imagine by the name it
basically takes the string acids and
then it breaks it by white space
so we see you know the two dogs seconds
if you see like it doesn't load case
with the terms like two is still capital
T
we see like the word snow there was a
period it didn't remove it
it only looks right
twice so now let's look at the stop word
analyzer
so what this analyze is going to do this
is going to lower case the characters
it's going to remove in just stop words
in the English language
and it's going to remove also non-text
captures
so we see the word two became lowercase
we see the period and after that snow
became removed
uh we saw like I think we had
uh in them are removed
and then elasticsearch has like this
default analyzer which
you see like in Long cases it removes
the period but it doesn't remove
stockwards
and you know elastic search has you know
this analysis for you know 50 plus
languages so you don't really need to do
anything
special for the language out of the box
so
so now we offered to analyzes so let's
actually kind of index these documents
and then kind of see how our system is
doing
so I'm going to create an elasticsearch
point which just basically needs the
host and board
um here's top of creating index I'm
doing something bad
um where you know the index exists and
dropping it
um don't do it in production
but
um yeah so we're going to create an
empty index
um since elasticsearch is kind of
parallel you can kind of distribute the
data in multiple pieces but since this
is like a small demo of 25 000 documents
I'm going to store all the documents in
one shot or one yeast
um elastic search can kind of understand
a schema of your Corpus but to be
explicit you're saying that we want the
description field to be indexed and I'm
going to provide you the URL and ID but
don't really process them
um the next thing that we're going to do
is give it a data frame
um if you want to prepare this data for
elastic search the first thing I'm doing
is I'm just getting development fields
and then elasticsearch requires a field
that it considers the document ID
yep that's all it's doing it's basically
yielding a dictionary for all the 25 000
rows that will process
and then we have a method that's going
to um the three of the documents which
we'll look at in detail a little bit
later
so let me just run this block and you'll
come back to the texting code later but
let's just create the index first
so
we're going to run that method that I
showed before
passing a client tell it that it we want
one shot
in elasticsearch has like some Helper
and endpoints that if you want you can
kind of get some details
so if you hit this all endpoint you see
that we have
we have one index
called non-splash which was the name
that we give the number of shots it has
when it was created all that kind of
metadata
so now I'm going to prepare the data for
indexing
so
um
this method basically takes the palace
in frame and then returns an iterator of
documents so I'm just going to run this
code block
and elastic surgery is going to start
processing and indexing it
so we have again about 25 000 documents
we see like on this maybe four core
machine
we are doing about 5000 plus documents
per second
like
um processing it you know doing those
operations that we talked about and then
storing it in the index I think that's
that's pretty good speed
um
yeah so again these are some
helpful endpoints if you want to know
like how much memory lasts instead of
just taking all that kind of stuff
so it seems like
um like 38 of what I think I gave it one
gigabyte of memory
um yeah so
this endpoint might be useful so this is
basically tells for our index what is
the schema of our fields
so in elasticsearch you can
I mean sometimes since elasticity is a
document database you don't necessarily
need to do like um
like a search maybe you know the
document that you're interested in you
just want to get all the fields so here
you're getting the document by the photo
ID
forgot to run this block
yeah so
so this is telling information on the
shots we see we know that we have to
move for one shot we have 25 000
documents and in this it's taking about
like 480.
okay so that was all the kind of logic
for inserting documents in elastic
search
I mean it's fine if you know this is
just using a libraries apis so at this
was not really interesting let's
actually look at what are the results
that we are getting from the system
so I have this query here two dogs
playing in the snow
and in elastic search to submit a query
we call the search endpoint
and you give it what query you want
so you can tell it I want you to search
for the square in multiple fields
um in our case we only have one field so
I'm just telling you to search all the
fields but there's only one field
I'm telling you to give me five
documents
so this is what the payload looks like
elasticsearch or in those space of
information retrieval you might hear the
term hits so we have five hits or five
results
we get the schema for our document and
we get the support and elastic search
things it should have
so let's try to see if we can explain
why it asks such things this document
should have to score
so the same request that you make you
can tell it explain to me why you think
it should have the score
so
you have the same pitch endpoint
and you'll see that there's a new field
called explanation
so for this document
the description of this photo was two
white dogs
so elastic search is saying it's giving
it a score of 14.7
because
it's the sum of two things
the first is
because the document has a documented
the query match for the word too
and because
the word dogs so it's a score of code
two in dogs
so why why does dogs get 8.7 score
first we see this you know boost of IDF
times term frequency just depends what
we covered in the slides
we see like how elastic searches compute
an idea so this formula is exactly what
we covered in the slice
in more detail about this is what I
computed n to B this is what I computed
um
the term frequency today so yeah you
won't go into details of this but
basically you can base if you believe in
that formula of being pretty fine you
can either dive into details and see how
each of these contributions contribute
to the final score
so I guess it's an explainable outcome
Okay so
and now let's actually look at the
results
um like ignore the algorithm let's just
look at the results
so we know how to fetch results right
which is called Client app search you
give the query which Fields the search
in our case it's just description field
and we can also tell it and analyze it
how do you want to process the query
so
let me just run this code block
so I have this method it's basically
given the query it tells you what is the
tokens and then we see the results
so for this query two dogs playing in
the snow
this is what the algorithm returns for
um which tokenizer did I give I gave the
English tokenizer or Analyze This
elasticity calls it
um
yeah the first image doesn't have the
word two but it looks like the hashtags
dog dogs got kind of cleaned up
I don't see dogs playing in the snow but
I guess technically images the dog is in
the snow
so one thing is like these documents are
kind of much shorter in length and
normally when elastic search money do
might be useful so just keep that in
mind a little bit
um we see like you know two cabins
covered with snow few mountain peaks
covered with snow
I mean again it's the same thing where
like the subject of interest is dogs not
necessarily
um these other things like technically
yes yeah the cabins there are two cabins
they're covered in snow but the real
real object of interest is dogs right
so yeah
so I have some place here that you know
if you want to spend maybe two minutes
or so to kind of play it around uh yes
foreign
here
and
um
you can play with the
name it
the different analyzers here so uh I was
going to cover this but since you
brought it up so it is kind of crazy how
some of the words get
um like I would think play would be like
Play playing would become play not PLO
plai but the stemming
token
um yeah so
um
I have some queries like just take a
look at the first five queries
and you know using this iPad widget
displaying some of the options
um take a look at how the results are
and maybe we can discuss them
um so maybe it's like four or five so
maybe like in two minutes or so we can
kind of discuss the results
and it's just you know like
um just focus on maybe the first five
results uh first by options you know
play with some of the tokenizers and I I
did ask like some
prompts here so we'll discuss them soon
so just you know playing with it a
little bit and we'll talk about it in
maybe two minutes
um while
um while people are playing with this
like are there any questions so far on
what we covered
um
is there something automatically
informed where you can have
more weights to certain words like where
the
like I guess
the word two would probably have less
weight in the search than a lot of snow
Yeah so uh in elasticsearch like when
you send a query uh you can actually
tell it how much you want to debate how
much you want to pay a specific token
maybe you can manually do that
um and you can also tell it you know if
a token appears in the title you know
being much more so you can create that
weary and elastic search to adjust the
supports accordingly but here like we
would hope like if elasticsearch can
understood the language like two would
be less important than thought but it's
not difficult
um the other approach that we'll cover
we'll see that it kind of does a better
job with that
yes
foreign
Topic in this space of search so the
next topic you'll be covering is like
embedding paste retrieval and we'll
cover to organization tab
um yeah but that's a great question
so many um just an interesting time let
me just quickly go over the results that
I noticed for some of these
um it's a little bit large with all the
images let me just reduce the font a
little bit
so you know for the query like person on
top of the mountain
I think I saw acceptable results for all
the analyzers so regardless of whether
you stop words or standard I think I
consider the results returned from each
of these analyzers kind of equally
relevant and about the same
um but if you take a look at you know a
picture of a man and messenger
you kind of see these things again you
know like which token is it stand up
look nice it's not removing some of
these stop works and you know I'm not
really seeing a man in the subject
so let me just you know use this
software documentation and now we kind
of see like man in the desert more kind
of a little bit more relevant interests
um but you know if you look at a picture
of a man in a desert or a person in a
desert
we kind of see like now you get
a little bit different results you know
you have person on a desert man in a
desert they mean the same thing but we
kind of seeing like different results
kind of creeping in
um the other main thing I want to talk
about is maybe like this way two dogs
playing in the snow
so here you know we get two white dogs
two dogs near mailbox baby elephants
just again it's not really capturing the
joke like tokens of time there but it's
not really actually intent correctly
and once uh maybe two final examples
like light at the end of the tunnel
so this is kind of like I guess like an
abstract kind of thing
um
I guess the first image might be
relevant technically it has the tokens
um but you know then you have like
things like eye style editing tunnel
like
doesn't seem that relevant
um and the final thing is to make a
point
um seven wonders of the world so here
for this query
it's not enough to just look at the
tokens right uh like we know that this
means like you know kind of seven
structures that are recognized to be
kind of architectural architecturally
magnificent right so it it doesn't it's
not sufficient to do like just a doping
match so you can see like these results
here are not really relevant at all
so yeah so this is token basic retrieve
also you know let's go to the
embedding piece of retrieval
so
um
yeah so we spend a lot of time here but
it's just to kind of highlight you know
why this approach is not sufficient
so
um
so we've looked at different tokenizers
that are available with elasticsearch we
looked at how fast we improvise you know
5000 plus documents per second is pretty
good
for such a small you know uh instance
that we have and elastic search is very
explainable
so we go into the next section and then
in base retrieval so again I'm going to
have like kind of five or six lives to
make sure we're kind of all in the same
age but
um yeah
so what just summarizing the issues that
we saw with token based retrieval one is
this lexical Gap right so car automobile
vehicle they all are the same conceptual
things but
um if you go by your token based things
we won't get any we won't get equivalent
results
the other thing is you know like the
same word can mean different things in
different contexts right
financial institution of a bank or like
Riverbank as in kind of like geography
kind of milestone
um another thing is you know we're
treating
um with the token-based approaches
between sentences just as a bag of words
but you know you might see the term
rumor bank but you you'll never see the
term Bank River right so you want to
have a model that kind of understands
um the grammar or understand how tokens
kind of naturally occur
and you know English can kind of be a
difficult language you can have the same
word appear in the same sentence meaning
different things right so here she'll
park the car so we can walk in the park
the same term means different things in
the same sentence even
so if you need a model that can
understand this
so this is where embeddings come
so if you take a look at this image so
we see like bananas and apples in this
3D space that we kind of created that
kind of close together in this space
um if you looked at Apple and Google
they're kind of close by in space and we
as humans know that okay it's a tech
company so that's why they're probably
in the space
banana and apple of food so probably
that's why they're close together
so
in this
um so this is where embedding is coming
um in like a 3D space in 100 dimensional
space in a five minute call dimensional
space can be represent Concepts that are
similar
kind of similar
so you know car and automobile if I give
it a vector of numbers
building like are they are similar
uh if I have a movie review that
contains a bunch of words you know I
have an emoji as an ice cream and it
says the ice cream was great I have
chocolate ice cream was the best they
bought me the same thing can you map it
to the same space with the same vector
so embeddings can help this embeddings
can give you
a solution for mapping similar Concepts
to like a similar floating Point vector
and regardless of Quantum Light
and regardless of the number of tokens
you will basically get a fixed dimension
of
um
uh Vector so normally people might do
like 100 Dimensions 256 Dimensions 5 and
12 dimensions
so that's basically like the high level
overview of synthetics so how do we
generate these embeddings that kind of
capture things that are similar
so in 2013 Google gave us this algorithm
work today
and the basic idea is you know a word is
basically the the meaning of a word is
basically the work the neighboring words
that kind of it Associates with
so in this like let's say you are given
like a large Corpus of English sentences
um if you look at this in an
unsupervised manner and you look at a
window size so here we have a window
size of two so for the word kitten we
look at two words that come before it
and two words that come after it
um
the words that you know are neighbors of
a word can kind of tell you
um some information on that word so we
see like kittens okay kittens people
consider them as cute kitten is like
Flames okay
um so maybe the vector for kittens is
something about like cuteness and uh
playfulness or whatnot same thing like
for people might use the same
words so that's why maybe these two
concepts might uh these two animals
might appear semantically close together
in this emphatic space
is to basically have a simple neural
network
where basically you look at the words
before it the words after it and you're
trying to predict the word and then
um you use the
internal hidden layer that you're
learning inside the network to learn the
things
um so the details of like the abandoning
means are not really that important this
is a classical algorithm and this is
kind of how
the first way that people run semantic
embeddings
um I want to take a small tangent so
here we're focusing on words
but I kind of want to show how this idea
can be used to learn semantic meaning
for things other than words
so
um
the idea of like things
um things are things that are equivalent
to like the neighbors
that it appears then
um can be useful more than these words
so Instagram has this uh blog post where
they say that if I look at the likes
that a user interacts in a session the
accounts that they interact with uh
probably tells me useful information
that these two accounts are kind of
related so in my feed if I like a
picture of a chat and then I like a
picture of a dog or animal puppy and
whatnot then those accounts are probably
related about animals or cuteness or
something like that
so you can kind of use this to kind of
learn semantically like what these two
accounts are basically kind of about
animals of texts or something like that
and one more example kind of showing
this
so Grandpa also used the same idea kind
of learn restaurant embeddings they
looked at session log data of
restaurants that people are you know
swiping or
ordering from
and give it basically able to create an
embedding of like okay these two
restaurants people are kind of scrolling
and looking at similar Foods so maybe
these two restaurants are kind of
similar and actually a data scientist
from the GrubHub actually presented the
stock in pi data in 2019 so if you're
interested you could watch this talk
so
this was like a tank independent show
how
like this word event approach is not
just on Words it's on a sequence and it
can be used for not just words but like
other semantically sexual ideas
so maybe let's go now back to uh
sentences and tokens
so
just like Google gave us worked back in
boom gave us birds in 2018
and birth can be pretty difficult to
explain
um but they're like maybe four ideas
that I want us to kind of factor
so just like word to back was like kind
of trained like in an unsupervised
manner of like okay the word
if like if you look at the neighboring
words you can kind of learn some meaning
but kind of uh kind of further build on
top of that idea
you give it like anti-wikipedia you give
it like entire like Google book Corpus
and you basically take those um words or
sentences you randomly mask some words
and you force the model to kind of learn
how to predict some of these words
so this unsupervised manner is one of
the key things like in these large
Transformer models like work
the other thing is tokenization right so
we saw how tokenization can kind of
affect
the result that you're getting and you
know white space is maybe not the best
way to just generate tokens so one novel
thing here is you can you can create
some words
so the word running you know instead of
just standing here to just run you can
kind of create two tokens run and then
um like the pound to kind of indicate
that it is the sub token
so what is the beauty of this approach
so over to back the first model that
Google's training is for the Google News
Corp was at over 1 million tokens
but bird this fancy new model it only
has 25 000 tokens because it uses
software tokenization
and even though it has less tokens it
can actually represent more than just
the pure tokens that work you might
provide
and the other thing is
um bird
um or like these Transformer models can
give you contact Choice synthetics so
for the same word that appears in the
same sentence or in different context it
can give you a contextualized synthetics
and that's like using attention and
whatnot but we're not really going to go
over it
today
so
um
the maybe the details of this is maybe
not that important but basically
people say like bird but bird has like
multiple encoders
so you know if I give it a sentence
but actually it's going to give me like
so this set this you know hello act you
know equal eats which is where I took
this image from
um this bird model has 12 encoders so
both is actually going to give me for
every token or every word it's going to
give me 12 different emphatics
so the word by itself doesn't really
solve the semantically similar problem
like it's trained on large data but if
you just take these embeddings like
first of all which embeddings you take
you average the word from weddings you
take a specific token embedding
so you actually need to maybe
tune the task a little bit
so this is an architecture that is very
common for kind of learning similar
ideas it's a two Tower you might hear it
like as a Siamese Network or like a buy
encoder architecture
the basic idea is if you have two things
that you know are similar you know feed
them into your model in this case the
bird model
however you want you know combine their
parents
take these embeddings and if you look at
like the cosine score uh
um if they are similar they should have
same cosine score but the cosine Square
should be one so you're forcing the
model to kind of adjust the feeds adjust
the embedding base to kind of learn a
better representation
so this architecture is kind of very
common
for uh here for sentences for other
domains also for kind of learning and
sexually similar things
so we actually covered a lot here but
just maybe summarizing a bit first we
started with word to back a very simple
our way to learn semantically similar
things we saw how it was extended by
other companies like Instagram and word
device for learning account embeddings
how to learn restaurant and medics
we briefly talked about birth and how it
kind of Builds on top of
like existing ideas
and we learned about how people use bird
in like these Chinese networks or 2000
networks to basically learn a better
sentence representation that captures
similarity better
so
in this second lab uh there's actually
two notebooks here that we can look at
um we're going to look at an embedding
that was uh trained and was hosted on
hug and face
so
um and let's see what kind of results we
get
so again if you're interested in
following along this will be the dance
retriever notebook and if there's time
we'll look also look at the
number three notebook
so let me just close all these steps
perhaps this it will increase it a bit
um
who created a notebook
so
um
in this in this notebook again we're
only looking at the captions
and we're going to use this model that
is available from How To Face called the
mini language model version 2.
so according to the documentation
this model will give you an embedding of
up to 384 dimensions
and this model will train on
um so again you know this is like word
that was kind of trained in an
unsupervised manner in a large data set
but then it has been further fine-tuned
with the Siamese kind of network on this
one billion second spare data set where
basically it has two sentences and they
act like conceptually similar
so where did this data sets come from it
came from like Reddit comments that were
considered duplicates or similar it came
from Wikipedia answers we have like
hosting pairs that were considered
duplicates
it had
um it's getting the pair from like stack
stack exchange where you look at the
title in the body so
um so it has things you know that are
considered similar
um so let me
and this is about 1 billion pairs of
this data set which is pretty large
um there are other models that we would
have used but
um
we look at this website here if it loads
the mini language model is still Place
one of their top models
we could have used this MB net based
model too so
um yeah if depending on the use case you
could use other models too
um
sorry sentence Transformer like the
author for this paper was the one who
kind of showed up word can be fine-tuned
um for learning cement somatic City
better so that's why we're using
sentence natural and because it's the
library that the original author created
so again let's look at the data set so
here's the model you know I can import
it from sentence Transformer sentence
transform it's going to download the
model from base hub
for hard to Define
it so
this model actually saw in the
architecture
it takes this Transformer model which is
a workplace model
and then it does cooling it combines all
these synthetics so it looks like it
takes the mean
um
mean of the tokens
and then balance from that is basically
the sentence of adding for the input
that you provide
so let's explore tokenization
so one thing that we know
is
it has subvert tokenizations
so
um there's a lot that's provided in this
output
so one thing to know is the first thing
you know you're given a text token but
you need to convert it to a new Mac ID
that's what this input IDs are
are you know these things are like
something about attention but you can
let's skip this for today
and so now we have these token
embeddings so this is what every token
will have in embedding but what we
really care about is
an embedding for the the entire sentence
so this is the sentence embedding using
this cooling technique of taking average
you can you can use other techniques too
if you're interested in how to combine
the pairings
so
so we see the original query had 59
59 chapters right
so
like 59 characters
and
if I split it
if I just consider it by light space
there would be 12 tokens
but
um
because but the tokenized that they're
using is using like sub words it becomes
like 18 tokens
and for each of those 18 tokens we have
an embedding of 384 dimensions
and the final sentence and value is 384.
because we're averaging
those and bennings
so
um
let's look at the vocab size for this
tokenizer
so
um you know it's not one million it's 30
000. in the entire model there's only 30
000 tokens
um let's see so maybe let me just go to
um
so one one issue with this you know
these large models is they did not
really do that development like long
with long uh
um the long input
so here I have an input that's like more
than and 5000 tokens
you see the spawning message that
basically says this model doesn't really
do well but
um inputs that are larger than 504
tokens
and you may face some errors here
so
yeah so the tokenized model really only
deals to it an input line to 500 on
tokens
so yeah so how do you compute the
embeddings you know the sentence
Transformer Library makes it very simple
you just call model.n code
and um so this is going to generate the
25 000
embeddings
I don't have a GPU here so this will
unfortunately take some time so for the
entire elastic search purpose you know
we were able to do like 5000 documents
per second so this will take some time
so once we have the embeddings
how do you compute similarity
so given a query
you also get the embeddings
and then you can since I normalize the
vectors I can just do the dot product or
you can do cosine in whichever
so you have the query and then you just
do a matrix multiplication and then you
basically get the similarity for that
query vector and four quarters
and then I'm just getting the top end
results
so this will take some time let me just
run this
um
and maybe while this is running
again I do have like a cell here where
you can play with themselves but
um
take some time okay let me just show the
results that I got from
running this offline
so
for this model
for the crane two dogs playing in this
notes
the top result you know there's no the
turn two is not there at all we see
brown and black dogs
and I think this is a very this is the
for me this is a very relevant result
uh the second result you know like the
white and a black dog it's technically
describing the same dog but it seems
like the models may be getting a bit
confused
and the other one you know
tan dog playing on snow
um definitely these results are more
relevant than what we saw with just the
pure doping base
and partly it's because like the model
is paying a little bit more attention to
these tokens
and because you know like this model on
top of being trained on a very large
data set is again trained on a one
billion data set Corpus right so bm35
approach token base is not trained on
anything right so they said this is
partly why these models perform really
well
um the other strong example that I found
from this data set is you know with a
great boiling going on a beach
the first query that came is you know
children enjoying each
so you know it's able to understand boys
no you know it's basically children and
you know the top itself is pretty
relevant to me
on the second thing couple on a beach
you know
yeah maybe like it's still relevant uh
people at the beach so it's doing it's
doing way better than just the pure
broken basis
um here's one example that's not really
doing so well right seven wonders of the
world like the world globe it's not
really getting it's not really doing the
translation well to the
um
yeah uh to like the seven architectures
that actually represent this
so let's see if the model completed
it looks like it did complete
um
so
yeah I think like the three examples I
covered kind of covered the main things
let me just show like you know a picture
of a man in the desert you know this is
the first language that we get and then
if I have a person in the desert it's
the same language so similar concepts
are bringing similar results
same thing like boy and girl on the
beach you know you have children
enjoying the beach they're getting the
same results for kind of like children
on people at least for the first few
results
and um yeah and then like light at the
end of the tunnel
okay here tunnel with lights
um
red tinge tunnel I don't know I mean
it's still I think the first image is
definitely what I consider relevant
um others are maybe not the best
okay so we
um we kind of saw how to use the hugging
face
we saw how to use the embedding
how to use that model that is uploaded
to how to face you kind of saw how much
more relevant results look
um
yes this is all happening like outside
yes yes uh this is so
um
yes so here
um so for token base uh female we use
elasticsearch here uh for this dance
retrieval like we basically
are Computing and betting and doing this
matrix multiplication uh online so
um so it's a bit slow so actually maybe
what I wanted to cover
was
um
so in the in the elasticsearch notebook
we needed a search we got a result in
about three milliseconds
but if we do this calculation the way
that we Define this
um it I think it takes
um yeah from three milliseconds to 200
milliseconds so it is expensive the way
it is currently defined during like this
matrix multiplication
so the next topic that we'll actually
look at is how can we kind of scale this
similarity of matching
match it's a good person
um
yeah so maybe we'll post things before I
go on to the next concert
um
is there a way to do that in Alaska
yeah so uh
yeah so I'll bring that up to extend
this effect
so
um since that is a little bit of time I
do want to cover one more thing
so we looked at embedding models that
use
text and it kind of saw an architecture
there given two texts we are able to
kind of learn similarity
but you can learn similarity from
different modality you can learn
similarity from text and from an image
and you know like if you have image
caption data
if this is the caption that people are
describing the image then they basically
mean the same thing right and what you
can actually do is you can map text and
images in the same space
so open AI again and release this model
click where basically images and texts
are mapped to the same embedding space
so what does that mean so given a text
you can retrieve relevant images given
an image you can you can search for
images or you can search for text
so it kind of solves this multimodaly
kind of problem
so
um yes maybe let me just quickly show
the results that I'm getting for this
model
um
so this result is from this quick
notebook here
so clip stands for this contrastive
language pre-training task
again just because of time I'm just
going to show the output
so
open AI kind of clicked they kind of
trained this data on
I believe they trained this on like more
like again one billion image image
caption data data set
so again here's the model uploaded in
hug and face
you can use sentence Transformer to get
this model
on this model if you see it has two
pieces it has a text model
and
it has a vision model
so it's this two tablet model
um then you know given a text you know
go to the text camcorder even an image
you'll go to an image encoder and the
embeddings will basically be in that
same space
so
um one thing to note is this model is
much more heavy so for just embedding
100 documents
it takes like 10 seconds or four seconds
so it is a pretty heavy model to run on
um actually this output is when I ran
this 100
GPU so it'll take much longer if you end
this life
um
yeah so maybe let me just show one thing
the results of this model
so
again
um
the output I mean using this model is
the same you know you get a query that
is an image or a text you encode it you
get the query vector and then you do the
dot product on The Matrix
foreign
and
um
let me just go to the slides to show
what results I got together
so
so here what's happening is I'm not
looking at the caption of the image I'm
sorry I'm not looking at the caption of
the image I'm
given a query I'm Computing embeddings
from the image and then getting the
similarity here
so this model
just by looking at this image of like
this brown and black dog
it's able to say like okay this one is
similar to this query
like what and this is for me the second
example is a pretty strong thing you
know like friends will be friends you
know it doesn't quite capture that it's
about two dogs
um the previous model was not able to
retrieve this but this image model just
by looking at this image it's able to
understand that this is kind of talking
about
friends and two dogs
another strong example that I liked
is you know this way in this query White
Sands
nothing in the caption kind of captures
that okay these are like two people kind
of in the beach and whatnot
but kind of by looking at image we kind
of get that idea so again this model is
just looking at the image it's not
looking at the
text
um
and finally this example that I was
hoping for
so seven wonders of the world so this
model again it was streamed on image
caption data so you know image caption
probably have things like okay you know
this is Machu Picchu it is one of the
seven wonders of gold right
um so but I think this model is also
able to benefit from looking at the
image so partly because it's an image
model and partly because you know the
training data was image caption data
which probably people have
um annotated that okay this is one to
Seven Wonders this model is able to
learn
and reformulate the squared images
um
yeah so that is basically the embedding
piece that covered a lot
um so kind of being saw in this notebook
like you know it takes 10 seconds it to
kind of
you can see how long this notebook took
so this notebook on
on
yeah so on a
on a GPU the stuff
um for one query to 46 milliseconds
completed this embedding on the entire
um documents so that can be pretty
expensive in a production use case
so how can we scale this one is to use a
vector database and to use a m and
combination
so
you know if you have these 25
000 vectors in this large emphatic space
you're given a query Vector how do you
find
how do you find uh relevant vectors
the simple naive way is to basically do
a Brute Force compassion with all the
vectors in there
yes
um
girl
I get like could be
put a density
um
so it's
is there both like
I guess like representations of like
for word but simple things
relationship between words and
also images in there as well because
like it's doing that with images that
the captions are
uh yeah so like
um the first embedding model the Mini
model like that it it
um it was strained on
some partial flicker data so
um so you know part of the one billion
pairs it did have like this kind of
image capture data so
um they're like dance factors
yes
um but um sorry the data is still like
text but like it may have like
like um in the flicker data like for the
same humidity maybe like multiple
captions that kind of describe it
um but yeah
yes
it's all text-based
um the second model
um was trained on text and image caption
test but the retrieval that I showed
only looked at the image
um
so
sorry before I go forward on a and so I
covered the
um clip model basically and fast and
maybe the results are not properly
captured like before I go to the
Internet section under any questions on
other
cool
um yeah so you have these 25 000 vectors
you're trying to find similar vectors
and the simple way to do it is a Brute
Force
um there are many ways to kind of
eliminate doing improved Force one
simple algorithm
which is called the inverted file index
is basically let's say you can kind of
break this High dimensional space
into like some clusters
the details of how to clusters field is
not important let's say we're getting
radically kind of break this into some
clusters you do provide this parameter
that defines how many postures you want
to be created
so here I broke the space into 15
clusters
so now I have 15 centroids
so now if I'm given a query Vector what
I first do is I compare against all the
centroids
and then I find okay which centroid is
the closest to me and then I only
compare vectors in centroid that is
relevant or that is similar to me so
so let's say you know we have these 15
cent release I have this this green
query Vector here
I did my comparison again it's all those
15 centroids and found out that this
centroid is the most similar to me
I have a high I have a parameter called
n probe that determines how many
clusters I look at
so because n probe is one once I found
the closest cluster to me I'm going to
look at all the
all the vectors that are inside that
cluster
so with an N probe of one with 15
clusters we're looking at looking at 1
15 of the search space
um if instead you did n probe equals
five you know once you once you did like
the comparison against all the centroids
you're going to compare against the
entire vectors inside those five
clusters so
um since you have 15 clusters and you're
probing five of them that's basically uh
one third of the search piece
so obviously like
um
and of course if you did n probe equals
15 and you have 15 clusters that's
basically doing a group for research so
your you have to spray it off where you
know if you have like hundred thousand
vectors million vectors billion vectors
you cannot you cannot feasibly
scan all the entire search speeds you
need to come up with some
some representation so that's why
there's a doubling in it like
approximate nearest neighbors search
because you cannot search all the entire
space
but if you have like a good clustering
algorithm or some other algorithms that
kind of break this large dimensional
space into a much smaller space
and you only look at the ones that are
relevant uh you can kind of reduce the
learning exhaustive search
and you know there are a lot of
databases that support a n so elastic
search I think since 8.5
supports our a n it doesn't
um there are much better implementations
than you know this algorithm inverted
file index so all these databases use
this other algorithm
um yeah so whether you know yourself
hosting or whether you're using managed
Solutions like iPhone or Google solution
um they're a great kind of a M Solutions
um
running a bit short on times I just
wanted to show like
um so if your data set is small and you
don't need like distributed
like Facebook has this Library paste
that basically
um allows you to kind of experiment with
these different embeddings
uh like different ways of creating an A
M
so it's like face dot index
um
this is basically a Brute Force index
and then
there is
dot IVF which is basically what we
covered
and it has much more other
implementations
um
yeah so maybe I just have one two more
slides I just kind of want to close this
before we use for any questions
um
so we kind of looked at retrieval I kind
of want to now bring this together
um
like comparing like embedding things to
do a building base which you want
so from the results it seems to be like
you should always use embedding research
label assuming you can deal with the
latency cost or like production cost
but what if you so this was a study that
was done where basically
these researchers took a model that was
uh trained on like Microsoft Bing search
results
um so when they use bm35 they got like
an ndct some evaluation metric scored
0.2
if they used the if they fine-tuned on
Microsoft things search results data
and they got a score of 0.4 when they
kind of compared on the same data set
but what if you use kind of like
different data sets
what if you use a model that is trained
on Microsoft Bing search results and
then you try to use it for retrieval on
quorum
so Coral is kind of similar to the
cerebral results so again it embedding
based retrievals did much better than or
did a little bit better than using just
pure token based approach
but what if you use like a model that is
trained on Bing and then you started
using it for like medical documents or
you started using it for tweets
um you start seeing like this embedding
based retrieval is actually doing worse
than just using pure token based
approach so
if you use these models of hugging face
and your Corpus is more
medical or more domain driven
the pure bm35 approach may do better
that's just something to consider
the other thing and this one and this is
the last slide I kind of have is a kind
of maybe was kind of comparing like bm35
and betting A3 is like a match versus
and you introduce one of them
so in this Chinese e-commerce company
they actually use multiple approaches
right they use bm35
they use embedding they use graph based
approaches so they use all these
approaches so when the user enters their
platform they get the recall they get
results from all of them they combine
them deduce them
um they apply some ranking on these
approaches
and one other thing is you know you
might rank them but when you present
them to the user you you know as a
business you may want to show ads you
may want to kind of detail some items so
not everything looks very similar so
this is basically kind of what is full
end-to-end stack might be for kind of
like an e-commerce kind of company so
that's retrieval which can include
multiple approaches the token based
embedding for even much more fancy and
approaches then you kind of write them
considering maybe like the users
information about the user information
about like past things that they may
search for information about like the
item
um and then you kind of do like some
business level ranking
so this is basically kind of like some
idea of what a company's background look
like and yeah that's basically
my last slide that I have here
um
yeah so you know just kind of
summarizing I hope you all feel a little
bit comfortable with what token basis
retrieval is what embedding basic
retrieval is uh how to use elasticsearch
how to use kind of the sentence
Transformer library to use existing
models that are in hug and face to
compute embedding similarity and a
little bit idea of how you might scale
and letting face retrieval with a and
then
um if you want to explore this material
a bit further
iPhone which is like one of the vendors
for a m they have this really great
series of blog posts that talk about
all these material in a much more
detailed and accessible manner
if you're kind of interested in this
case of information retrieval and like
this one is from uh from a academic
conference where they have like six
hours worth of slides kind of talking
about this material in much more detail
if you're interested in this material
like from an e-commerce setting Home
Depot has this nice talk where they talk
about some of the details
that we kind of talked about and this is
a good blog post on a m and some of the
details there
yeah I think this is the last slide I
kind of had
um any questions that I could help
answer or
I have been curious with uh
okay
um I was curious with the uh when you
talked about clip the one that's able to
uh yeah text how you're also pointing
out that like the friends will be
friends one was pretty impressive
because the text feels entirely kind of
irrelevant and maybe try to have the
information for the two dogs
how did the model kind of realize that
the image contains more information that
maybe doesn't pay attention
is that like built into the inference
step or is there a part of the training
that I figure yes if you were a stick
and start season unique friends yes so
it has to be kind of like the training
game that said let's play it on one
billion uh image pairs from like a crawl
done on on the internet and
um so they were probably most likely
image pairs that kind of had that had
that idea expressed their
you know like people annotated like that
or there were some memes or something
like that that had this so just like
because otherwise it's just looking pure
at an image you cannot really tell that
so so that's one of the beauty of like
um having like that two Tower kind of
approach where different modalities you
can force like uh kind of learning this
representation and that approach is
actually used like you know for videos
and also like for
yeah in other domains also
yeah and like that's the input sitting
model I mean for instance the full Tuple
it's not like they're right it's the
multiple of both text and input is being
said at the same time yes for training
yes for training the text and image
about fantasy culture
we have
a question so um also about kind of a
clip is it possible to provide a query
that is an image or is it something
where it kind of goes one way from
from text to image or is that just
I use it actually you can uh your input
can be text we can query and
um yeah so it can be eaten without
ending
um regardless of the modality it will
map to the same embedding space of 500
call detections
I guess there are no more questions
thanks for your time for the last
session
I hope this was helpful
um you have to
um
you have the slides and this Cooper Hub
instance may go down a bit later but
um I do have in the repo
like a wine Hub instance so you should
be able to hopefully
play along without you know too much
setup otherwise you know just take a
look at the notebook it's luckily you
know hugging phase elastic service
libraries are pretty easy to use so um
there's not much for involved cool yeah
thanks everyone
[Music]
[Applause]